he's probably the most charismatic guy
I've ever met my whole life I was like
I'm curious do you think we are low
ethics do you think you have a sort of a
looser ethical criteria than most people
for business I think that we have a
looser attitude yes but by the way I
think it's significantly above the line
of like good like right like for example
most people are like I can't priests all
product that I don't have and I'm like
in my head I'm like who cares just
refund to people and like you haven't
you something I'm not saying steal money
I'm saying advertise something it
doesn't exist you can get demand and
proved a man and then you refund the
money let's say you steal from them but
yeah you are lying and so I think that's
ethical right yeah I think we definitely
have a looser definition than the
average person I would say the average
maybe the average business person even
but there is you know I think the
problem here is there's no standard
right there's no there's no definition
for what's ethical what's not it's
completely subjective and judgmental and
so the hard part is you know for us we
think there's a line between right and
wrong and we're on the right side we we
think we have a safe margin of a buffer
where we're in the right but for other
people their line might be in a
different spot yeah but that's because
most people aren't aggressive but
anything that I do
I would I would suggest to my mom that
she buy whatever I'm promoting or like
it's like do I want my family to use
this or or if I told them about what I'm
doing what I like do I want to hide this
right and I don't I'm I'm anything that
I could do I'm not afraid to tell so I
met this guy once this guy had reached
out to me about we're building his
product called blab and blab was getting
popular this guy reached out hey my name
is Billy I'm from you know for comers
from like Santiago or the firm X or
somewhere and let him and he was like
I'm coming up to California coming to
San Francisco I want to meet you and I
want to talk to you about this company I
was like okay
I don't know about that like most of
people who that are users of a product
or not usually people I want to like do
meetings with necessarily but he said a
bunch of stuff in his email that made
him sound amazingly legit he was like my
family started the first television
station in Mexico we you know I own all
these different like music festivals and
he said he sounded like super legit but
his emails written with blue text font
and like different sizes of text yeah
no no not like that like it was like
IKEA Cho's like no I'm good at my emails
are blue and not the like copy-paste a
little purple thing it was like this was
just his style so I was like I don't
know this guy's a joke or not anyways we
go out to dinner and I have very low
hopes we go to a sushi place and I walk
in and I see probably the most handsome
guy I've ever seen and this guy Billy
was extremely well-put-together he's
like in a suit and tie
he looks legit he we sit down on the
table he orders the omakase which is
basically chef's choice like $200 each
sushi dinner and he's like I got this
don't worry and I'm like okay I'm
starting to believe it but you know
could be it could still be someone who's
faking it and he starts telling me a
story and this guy's completely legit
he's probably the most charismatic guy
I've ever met my whole life I was like
you know if if I swung that way I'd be
in love right now like this guy is
amazing so at the end of the dinner I
asked him a question I said hey you know
you're a very persuasive guy like this
was you clearly are good at this right
you're clearly very personalizing very
charming I said I used to think I'm that
way till I met you basically I used to
think I was in the sort of top tier of
that but I always sort of had this
hesitation of like you know should I use
my my powers for good or evil type of
thing like where do you draw the line on
using this but this guy's legit
he was a real completely legit and and
so he really was wealthy very successful
very smart very charming all that good
stuff and so I asked him I said you know
what do you think he goes my rule is
this because if your intentions are good
then it's all fair game and so he was
like he was like it all the matters of
the intent if you're trying to scam
people if you're trying to con people if
you're trying to not deliver value if
you're trying to just get something
that's a good situation for you and not
for the other person then you shouldn't
be doing it what you shouldn't be using
all these powers
persuasion sake but if you think you are
genuinely gonna help people if you think
you are genuinely in the right if you
think you're gently working for a good
cause if your mission is pure if your
intent is good then it's all fair game
you should use it to the max and I was
like all right Billy thank you very much
for this incredible I completely agree
with him and if you study you know like
persuasion and charm and I use it in the
form of copywriting that's all some
people are born better but it's a
teachable skill and I always tell people
like what I'm gonna tell you it's gonna
sound like evil like I'm gonna teach you
how to manipulate people but make sure
you use it for good right because you
can easily use this for bad
[Music]